[musique]
bâtiments noirs appartements noirs
terre noire
Maintenant, nous faisons des orthophotos qui sont des images de
hauteurs de différents côtés de la détruite
bâtiments avec des lignes endommagées
transmission de puissance par ponts
on fixe les dimensions de la même façon avec les champs
l'entonnoir
nous enregistrons la nature de la destruction du conducteur
qu'il y a une trajectoire de projectile et que
tout sera prouvé au niveau international
crimes égaux de la Fédération de Russie contre
population civile
[musique]
à la fin de la 14e année, j'ai étudié
piloter des hélicoptères d'aile dans la 15e année
est allé dans les zones de guerre à l'est
de l'Ukraine à se produire en soirée
L'Ukraine a besoin de drones de différents types
hélicoptères et type d'ailes à effectuer
diverses tâches tant au front que sur
évacuation des civils si une personne part
au sol et ne le voit pas d'en haut
beaucoup plus de chance d'obtenir
désagrément de la situation au combat ou à la semelle
Si une personne a au moins des informations d'en haut
la perte de main-d'œuvre peut être minimisée
comme ce départ était le deuxième, je l'ai noyé à nouveau
il n'y avait pas de satellites, mais l'échantillon a été perdu
et juste bien pris d'assaut, c'est bon Phantom
voler avec des satellites va chez nous
maintenant une nouvelle puce
cercle a donné à ce processus un nouveau terme John
il ne pleut pas beaucoup en allant à la maison
nous avons une communauté d'opérateurs
Des drones de différents types Nous partageons nos compétences
Nous partageons notre expérience car maintenant en
De nouvelles machines yaki arrivent en Ukraine
qui ont leurs propres spécificités de travail et qui ne
vous pouvez trouver Aucun avis sauf que
en anglais c'est très rare
maximum
en plus je travaille
Eh bien, maintenant il y a une session de formation
vols de soldats des Forces armées ukrainiennes à proximité de
conditions de terrain et afin de
pour élaborer les tactiques de conduite du renseignement et
couvrant le carabinier afin de
dans les conditions de la bataille, tout était aussi sûr que possible
et le plus rapidement possible
l'expérience doit être partagée, maîtrisée
différents types de drones sont indispensables
enseignez à ceux qui débutent et font
un tel réseau dans l'armée pour que plus de gens
a pu utiliser des drones en toute sécurité
il 20 sont différents Par exemple si
tais-toi, il y a un changement d'équipe et quoi
plus de gens savent comment faire que
en plus ça sauve des vies
chaque drone a sa propre réserve de temps de vol
et puis il faut recharger Et où
charge si, par exemple, l'électricité
il n'y a pas
plus il y a d'oiseaux, plus le temps est long
nous avons besoin de tels hélicoptères pour voler
Il était difficile de détruire les stations ennemies
radio-électro-combats qui interfèrent avec
travail des Drones Le drone peut tomber Le drone peut
se perdre Drone peut probablement continuer
itinéraire
nous avons besoin d'armes. Ils sont venus à nous
envahisseurs avec des armes, ils sont armés
amenés et tués dans des conflits avec des armes
notre population locale a visité la nôtre
les soldats ont tiré sur nos maternités
hôpitaux écoles ils en ont fait des armes nous
nous devons résister avec des armes de cette façon parce que dans
Nous sommes en guerre, nous avons besoin d'armes de toute sorte
le ciel pourrait être couvert par une arme qui pourrait
détruirait l'équipement ennemi à distance
dangereux de détecter cet équipement ennemi
bloquer son travail et neutraliser
c'est la seule façon de gagner
[musique]
L'Ukraine ne défend plus seulement ses propres
territoire Et aussi le monde civilisé tout entier un
si vous voulez soutenir l'ukrainien
l'armée
lutte efficace contre l'ennemi
acheter et nous envoyer des drones ou
vous soutenez avec de l'argent les fonds qui sont impliqués
en achetant des Drones, ces fonds reviennent
Les antécédents de Serhiy Prytula et la fondation sont vivants
Foy Ukraine
Non, je suis sur mes mains
ok tu veux
Eh bien, pourquoi l'emmenons-nous? Et que faire?
[rire]